my name is Andrew Quentin and I'm an
assistant professor of religious studies
in the Department of Religious Studies
at Yale University and I work on the
Buddhist traditions of Tibet and
Himalayas we're here today in the by
Niki Rare Book and Manuscript library it
is a place that has a very wonderful
collection of Tibetan and Himalayan
woodblock prints and manuscript texts
but they also have a really wonderful
collection of portable Tibetan religious
scroll paintings called tong codes so
we'll be looking at some of those
paintings here today tanka is Tibetan
portable religious painting it's a
scroll painting so it could be rolled up
and easily transported subject-matters
are almost always religious in nature
tanka painting could be commissioned by
high Lama for ritual purposes or it
could be commissioned by an ordinary
family in the event of a death in the
family for another kind of religious
purpose so painting our religious
painting was a great act of Merit making
it in traditional Buddhist societies
Tibetan tanka paintings vary greatly in
terms of subject matter in style and
iconography and the kinds of figures
that they depict but there are certain
key elements that are common to almost
all Tibetan tanka paintings
so first the central painting would be
prepared on canvas canvas was usually
white cotton that was framed in a
stretcher a kind of gesso was applied to
it then the painter would usually lay
out the Econometrica so the kind of
framework of gridlines and the outline
of the central figures the deities or
the buddha those lines would then be
overlaid with paint or ink
so the outlining was done first and then
gradually the colors would be added
usually first the background and then
the details of the figure and then
finally the face would be done the eyes
and the guild work so most Tonka
paintings actually have a kind of liquid
gold that's applied to them but once the
painting was finished that was really
only the first part of the
struction of a Tonka painting the canvas
would be taken off of its stretcher and
then would be set within a complex
brigade frame
so most Tonka's like this one have an
interior framework with several kinds of
alternating colored brigades and then
that was set within a larger brocade
frame and then at the top in the bottom
they usually had wood bars that would
help to stretch the Tonka so that it
would lay flat while hanging on the arm
and you can see on the bottom here there
are ornamental ends that were usually
placed on the wooden bar and then
finally there was a curtain that was
attached to the top of the Tonka that
could be raised up when the Tonka needed
to be displayed either for ritual
ceremonies or even if it was just being
left open in a shrine but if the
painting needed to be transported or
protected in some way then the curtain
could be lowered and that would protect
the painting from the elements from
sunlight or dirgo dust or things like
that so Tibetan painting is generally
rigidly defined traditional Tibetan
painters had a little leeway in terms of
crew expressing their own kind of
creativity so what this means is that
the detailed figures the deities the
Buddha figures had proportions that were
clearly delineated within texts and so
one of the painters first tasks would be
to sort of translate the econometrics
that were transmitted in texts into
visual form and so every figure
including the figure of a Buddha that
you see here would have its proportions
sort of rigidly laid out and so a
Tibetan painter would lay out a series
of gridlines that would determine the
proportion of the face to the body and
the body torso to the overall figure it
would guide the painter on where to
place the eyes or other important aquino
graphic features of a Buddha such as the
cranial bump called the huge Misha on
his head
there were also strict descriptions of
the kinds of hand gestures called mudras
or the physical pop body postures or leg
postures called asanas these were also
clearly laid
in tests so once the econometrics for
the central figure was laid out and the
secondary figures were laid were laid
out then the painter had some
flexibility in terms of how he laid out
the background and that could in some
instances include kind of narrative
stories like we see in this painting
here or it could include kind of
environmental features things like
mountains or streams or at the sky and
things like that and that was really the
realm in which the artist had great
license to express his own creativity so
this painting was a gift to the by Nicki
library from Edna Brier Schwab in 1967
and it was probably part of a set we
have at least one other painting that
was part of this set and the central
figure is the historical buddha
shakyamuni buddha and the scenes around
it describe a collection of his past
lives called Jatakas now the Jatakas
were a really important form of Buddhist
literature they are found in Buddhist
traditions across Asia in the Pali Canon
in the Tibetan and Chinese canons as
well there were hundreds of different
Jataka stories and there were several
which were really important in tibet and
this is one of those stories so the
central image here is the historical
buddha shakyamuni and he's shown in a
kind of traditional form he seated
cross-legged on a lotus throne and the
Lotus is supported by a throne held up
by force no Lions very traditional
Tibetan motif you'll see that he sitted
with cross legs and his left hand is
held in meditation posture it holds a
begging bowl here looks like it's filled
with flowers and his right hand is held
in the mudra of touching the earth
called a Bhumi sparsa mudra and this is
a representation of the moment of the
Buddha's enlightenment and surrounding
the central figure then is this great
narrative from the story of the Buddha's
previous life as Prince Vasant Ora so
the Jataka stories were were very
important
form of Buddhas literature that
described the Buddha's past lives they
were often written in the form of
morality tales which describe a
particular kind of virtue that the
Buddha had to practice in a past life in
order to eventually become the Buddha
himself and the Buddha the center story
then was one of the most important of
these Jatakas stories in Tibet where it
was not only recorded in texts but it
was also performed in stage plays and
was widely widely beloved across Tibet
this tanka tells the Jataka story of the
Buddha in a previous lifetime where he
was reborn as a deer so it's known as
the rourou Jatakas story the painting
was given to the by niki library by Edna
Brier Schwab in 1967 and forms part of a
series with the by Nicky's painting of
the Vasant Oda Jataka also given by Edna
Brier Schwab these two paintings
depicted the central figure in similar
ways although there are some interesting
differences but of course the narrative
story being told in in the background is
is very different the central figure of
this painting is the historical Buddha
Sakyamuni and he seated represented in
the traditional way he's wearing the
robes of a monk he's seated with his
legs crossed in what's called the Vajra
posture with his feet on opposite thighs
his left hand is resting in his lap in
the gesture of meditation holding a
begging bowl and his right hand lightly
touches the ground in the earth touching
gesture known as the Bhumi sparsa mudra
which tells us that it's depicting the
Buddha at the moment of his
enlightenment now the Buddha sits on top
of Lotus and the Lotus itself is
supported by a throne which is held up
by four mythical creatures called snow
lions the Buddha has a Nimbus of light
around him and a halo behind his head
and there's also this really wonderful
floral motif surrounding the figure the
floral motifs of both of the paintings
in this series but this painting in the
Poisson Taylor painting are similar but
they're slightly different showing that
there was some attention
to creating a kind of difference in
individual paintings so these two
paintings would have been part of a
large series perhaps more than a dozen
paintings that would have been hung on a
wall all all at once that together would
represent the corpus of stories about
the Buddha's previous lives
this tanka represents a collection of
deities from a very important ritual
text known in the Tibetan is the Bardo
to DRO or the liberation through hearing
in the intermediate state which is
better known as the Tibetan Book of the
Dead and it is a text that is
traditionally read when someone is dying
or shortly after his death and the
collection of deities the the ritual
cycle of deity is described in that text
are often commissioned as part of a
painting when a person in the family
dies as well and that's what we see here
so this painting comes from Nepal it was
probably painted in the 1950s and
although it's not very kind of high
style painting the execution is fairly
provincial it's a very interesting
ethnographic example of how this kind of
religious artwork was used in its ritual
context so the central figure in this
painting is the tantric Buddha called
Samantabhadra he's blue in color seated
in the Vajra posture with his legs
crossed and holds in his lap his consort
and they're seated in sexual union and
surrounding them in these smaller round
ELLs than are the 42 peaceful deities of
the Tibetan Book of the Dead at the top
you have these various guitar guitar
buddhas on the lower register you have
some of the protectors but the most
interesting part of this painting from
an ethnographic perspective are in the
bottom register we see that Nepalese
family that would have been the family
who commissioned this painting in the
center in the small kind of halo
kneeling with their hands in prayer in
Anjali mudra r /
the wife or the widow and the daughter
of the person who had died and
surrounded perhaps by other male and
female members of the extended family we
see the man and women both dressed in
traditional Nepalese garb you also see
some figures who are smaller these were
likely children in the family the men
carry umbrellas
one of the women holds up a flower
perhaps as a kind of offering and one
very interesting feature of this
painting is that the female figure who's
in the center whether or not this was by
design on the part of the painter has
her feet which are literally stepping
out of the frame of the painting which
creates this great sense of liveliness
and you also see really interesting kind
of pieces of how this painting would
have been constructed so in the lower
left hand corner you see the outline of
a dog perhaps you know a family dog
which was done an outline but was never
put into into actual painting so if we
look at the back of the painting then we
see a further evidence of the ritual
context in which a painting like this
would have functioned in many ways the
rear of the painting which usually holds
some kind of inscriptions were as
important if not more important than
what was painted on the front side so
the first thing we notice is that each
one of the central deities depicted on
the front has on the back a series of
ritual letters these were Tibetan seed
syllables home in home and these were
inscribed on the back of the painting as
a part of the consecration ritual which
would help to in live in that the
painting itself it was a way of inviting
the kind of numinous essence of the
deities depicted on the front to reside
within the painting thereby activating
it another interesting piece of the
inscription on the back is this long
string of Tibetan texts written in a
somewhat unskilled hand but tells us the
circumstances in which the painting was
commissioned who the family was who the
officiating Lama was and the date in
which it was constructed this is a very
beautiful painting that was given to the
binding
library by an anonymous donor a Yale
graduate from the class of 1929 and it
shows a collection of raffle protector
figures these are protectors of the
dharma of the numa tradition of Tibetan
Buddhism now in Tibetan Buddhism we have
many kinds of of iconography we have
figures of the Buddha of the historical
Buddha of celestial Buddhas of tantric
Buddhas we have other historical figures
like great Lamas of the past and we have
meditational deities that can be
peaceful or wrathful we have
representations of great Bodhisattvas
but in the Tibetan Pantheon we also have
an important collection of protectors
and these were beings some of which are
believed to be enlightened some of which
are said to be just kind of mundane or
ordinary worldly beings but they have
been sort of bound under oath to help
protect the teachings of the Buddha
within Tibet
and that's what we see here and it's not
one single protector but a whole
constellation of protectors that would
have been important to a specific
tradition of Tibetan Buddhism the
central figure of this painting is as of
yet unidentified but we know through
inscriptional evidence on the reverse
that it was aligned with a specific
branch of Buddhist teachings from the
Nima sector the ancient tradition of
Tibetan Buddhism the central figure
bears resemblance to certain known
protectors although there are a number
of interesting differences so its
identification is still open to
interpretation but we see that the
central figure blue in color with six
arms and four faces surrounded in flames
standing on the Lotus throne and he's
surrounded by a panoply of other figures
some of which are can be identified
others have not yet been identified but
we can see that the execution of this
painting is really very very fine
quality the colors were created from
traditional pigments from ground
minerals or
vegetable matter or insect cocoons and
we also see very very fine gold work
where gold is liquefied and then held on
to the painting with glue but you see
very very fine gold detail in the robes
of the central figure and in the
surrounding figures as well when we look
at the back of this painting we see very
interesting elements of its ritual
consecration so traditionally when a
Tibetan tanka painting is completed the
painting itself is considered to be
really a kind of receptacle and empty
shell a mere representation of the
figures on the front and it's only once
the consecration ritual is completed
that the figures on the front are
ritualistically brought to life so one
of the most important elements of that
kind of consecration is the inscription
of seed syllables so we see on on parts
of the of the main figures body so here
we see a collection of the seed
syllables that would have been placed in
various parts of the central figures
body and those then become points in
which the body speech and mind qualities
and activities of the numinous essence
of that deity to come down and actually
reside within the painting itself at
which point the painting becomes
activated so that the painting is no
longer a mere representation of the
deity but in fact is the actual
manifestation of that deity itself
empowered to act just as that deity
would another interesting feature of the
consecration that we see on the back of
the painting are these two sets of red
handprints that would likely have been
placed by the ritual lama himself as a
means of imparting some of his own power
into the painting and we see one very
clear set of hemp prints at the top and
a slightly lighter set of hand prints at
the bottom we have no way of knowing
whether they were handprints of the same
person or not but one of the interesting
feature of the first set of hand prints
are the two thumbs on the right hand
this story is known as the Jataka of the
starving tigress and it's account we're
in in one of his previous lives the
Buddha was born as a prince where as he
sets out on a hunting party comes across
a tigress and her starving cubs and
through an act of great generosity and
self-sacrifice offers his own flesh and
blood to the tigress so that she might
be able to feed her own Cubs and so like
many Jatakas it's a more it's a morality
tale that teaches about the necessity
for the practice of compassion and
self-sacrifice on the path to Buddhahood
the story was much loved by Tibetans who
knew the account and traditionally the
story is said to have taken place at a
location near the cabman new Valley in
Nepal where it's popularly known as
number Buddha but the Tibetans call it
tug mo luging the place where the prince
offered his body to the tigress so on
the rear of the painting we don't see
much in terms of inscriptional evidence
but there is one small inscription which
tells us that this painting like most
Jataka paintings were part of a larger
series and in fact those series would
need to be arranged in a very specific
order and they were usually carefully
marked each painting was carefully
marked on the back so that we would know
which in the series it would come so
here this painting is marked as the
third on the left in 1950 the Yale
alumnus Eliot Beecher McCrae travelled
to India and then eventually on dissa
Keene where he met the Maharaja Chu Gill
or the Dharma King Tashi Namgyal who
offered McCrae this lovely Tonka of
manjushri which he then his family then
later donated to the Beinecke elibrary
the figures in the painting were
reportedly modeled after McRae's own
family who had accompanied him on his
trip to Sikkim soon after his return
McCrae became president of the
publishing giant EP Dutton where he
arranged for the release of several
climbing tales including WH Murray's the
story of Everest
and the Mount Everest reconnaissance
expedition by Eric Shipton but among
McRae's greatest publishing successes
was Austrian climber Heinrich errors
memoir seven years in Tibet the central
figure in this painting is manjushri the
bodhisattva of wisdom often described as
the emanation of the Buddha's own wisdom
and he's depicted here in his
traditional iconographic form in his
right hand he holds a blazing sword and
this is the sword of wisdom that cuts
through ignorance and in his left hand
held in the gesture of teaching near his
heart he holds the stem of a lotus which
rises up above his shoulder and on top
of that Lotus is a traditional Tibetan
religious text in the text is of the
Prague neo-primitive sutras were the
perfection of wisdom sutras also showing
Mandir she's an embodiment of wisdom
you